of talk to me about what's the agent on
the agenda for you with the prime
minister boris johnson today in terms of
your region's security security
well i think it's not just my region
security it's actually the security of
all of europe which is at stake i think
that we have seen that naivete about
putin about putin's russia over the past
three weeks has completely evaporated i
suppose the next step that we need is
the fear of putin and upput and russia
also has to evaporate if we look at the
ukrainian people
we can see
an incredibly strong determination not
to be subjugated not to allow this
imperialist imperialistic dictator
destroy their country destroy their
independence destroy their way of life
so what we have to do is in always
continue to support ukraine which we are
doing um militarily humanitarian with
medicines with fuel with food with
everything but at the same time
it's very important that uh in europe
and in nato especially we shore up our
own defenses and
shore up the entire eastern flank from
the baltic down to the black sea
this is actually already happening it's
a very very good signal uh we need to
keep up those efforts and uh russia has
to understand
that any uh escalation outside uh an
international territory
would be devastating because of course
the combined uh might of nato is simply
not comparable uh to uh the russian
military yes talk to me about how you're
bolstering your own country's security
you talked about it a little there and
extra nato troops in your country
bolstering that eastern flank and i was
reading um interestingly earlier that
more people are enlisting into the
volunteer brigades of latvia's national
guard uh over the last few days more
than over the whole of the last year
this is a real concern for the people of
your country getting their security
measures in place for any kind of
russian aggression on your soil
of course it is but for years we've been
bolstering our defenses we have been
spending over two percent of our gdp i
think this year it's about 2.2 2.3
percent of gdp uh we just took a
government decision to increase that to
two and a half percent uh so we will
continue to bolster our own defenses uh
we have a a very modern very efficient
fighting force and we are seeing now
that the voluntary recruits
coming in is unprecedented uh people in
my country
are very loyal patriots and this is a
concrete step that people are doing
people are asking themselves what can i
do to help so many are donating money
we've had huge huge inflows of private
donations companies are offering all
kinds of goods that they have to be
shipped to ukraine uh
uh
people are offering their homes opening
up their homes we don't have
a problem with big refugee centers
because basically most of the or all the
ukrainians that are coming to our
country
are being taped and taken open armed
into people's homes so
people are very engaged we see what is
happening there we understand that it
has everything to do with us but with us
not only as latvians or as a baltic
nation but as europeans uh and this is
uh what we have to
realize and we can stand up to it and we
must stand up to it yeah we focus on
what you can do militarily and but i
know that the joint expeditionary force
the summit that the prime minister boris
johnson is hosting including latvia
lithuania the netherlands swedens in
norway all the members this week and the
prime minister said that he wants to
focus not just on the military aspect of
defence
but
those
the resilient aspects that go beyond our
military footing what other kind of
measures can you put in place to resist
vladimir putin's threats
well the first
the basics is already there that is a
complete realization of what we're
dealing with an aggressive dictator who
is attacking a neighboring a peaceful
neighboring country uh so the the joint
expeditionary force of jeff is is a very
important part of the response against
that uh it's it's it's a it's a great
initiative it fits within the broader
framework of nato uh and what it is is
is a rapid uh deployment uh capability
across uh all of the the north of europe
uh to come to the aid of one another
as the case may arise to perform
exercises together to keep the baltic
sea uh open in the north sea so uh these
this is very important but of course uh
uh
there are there are many other things
that we can do uh to strengthen our
resilience and that is also uh isolating
russia so this war is already having the
impact in my country in britain
throughout the world in terms of our
economies the the ukrainians are paying
for the war with their lives with their
physical infrastructure with their
schools with their hospitals that are
being destroyed we're paying through it
through higher energy prices
and some other inconveniences in in in
terms of the flow of goods but this is a
small small cost to bear so we as
politicians have a responsibility to
explain to our our our citizens uh what
is happening and why it's happening uh
it's all part of a sense of the war
effort and the process of isolating
putin's regime has tremendous costs for
the russian economy but it will also
have costs for ours but once again these
costs compared to what we know is and we
see on the screens happening in ukraine
are minuscule and this is what we need
to do is to uh
understand and convey to our citizens
what the cost of this war is to us and
that we have to bear this cost uh the
the other option is uh complete physical
destruction as we see in ukraine
can i just ask you something that you
will have a unique view on as a prime
minister as a leader of latvia we talk
about the west we talk about nato we
talk about europe being so much more
united as a result of what is going on
in ukraine and
russia's invasion there we talk about it
being close-knit and being brought
being brought to be more unified do you
get a sense of that can you put it into
words for us what that's like as a prime
minister to be talking to other world
leaders and being united against such
atrocities that we're seeing unfold on
our screens
well i can say that i and my
predecessors for years
since the invasion uh in in georgia in
in 2008 we have been uh raising our
voices and saying that russia is not uh
like us the the government of russia is
uh heading towards autocracy then it was
heading towards the capitocracy now i
think it's a full-blown dictatorship
and for years we were not necessarily uh
listened to so much because there was a
a great consensus that no no if if you
engage correctly with putin then things
will be fine well now that myth has been
shattered and i can say that at the
meetings i am now attending uh it's it's
palpable the unity uh for example at the
heads of of of the european union we met
in in in paris in versailles for a
couple of days last week
we spent long hours speaking but these
were not the typical
european arguments about a small minor
clauses everyone was unified as to what
the problem is and what we spent the
hour speaking about is what more and
what what can we do more effectively to
stop this atrocity so there's complete
unity around the european table
there's complete unity around the nato
table as well and this is this is one of
the side effects i think putin never
counted on i think he underestimated
democracy he viewed our arguments and
our differences opinion as a weakness
but as it turns out that
democracies can and must be very strong
especially in the in the face of
imperialistic aggression and we are uh
coming up to that
and we are responding i think in a much
much much harsher manner than than putin
ever expected and we have to persevere
this is our uh mission right now is to
persevere and and essentially not let
putin win this war of aggression yes the
ukrainian prime minister put it so
succinctly well the world's eyes are now
open we never closed our eyes for a
second and many of russians neighbors
like yourself you didn't close your eyes
for a second either and just a final
question on peace talks we did have some
positive uh noises coming out of russia
over the weekend offering a glimmer of
hope peace talks have been paused today
nothing coming out of those we hope that
they will resume at some point later
today or tomorrow how much hope are you
holding out from those peace talks
i am convinced that putin will stop only
when he is stopped and when he is
stopped then i'm certain the
negotiations will start and they could
even be very quick putin must be stopped
that is the only way to get him to come
to the negotiating table